welcome chess lovers fans and
enthusiasts my name is Dennis LaRue I
will be playing the people I'm
accompanied by the one and only
Laurence hello I'm getting an ad for
rallies thanks
okay you two may be getting an ad for
rallies at home all right let's get this
dream kicked off the basic ground rules
are we only accept rated rated
challenges uh what do we claim you three
plus two five oh I like five oh yeah
like I like shorter be two plus two you
know that sounds like a very solid time
control 500 it is five Oh drunk
lifeguard hmm suspicious oh he's gone
now there's lifeguards all gone no fired
well I see one familiar handle on there
mr. David Chopin plays in our quads Oh
drunk lifeguards back again well you can
wait buddy whoever you might be let's go
David
we're playing just gonna say hello to
some people in YouTube chat hey and
what's happening to my Oh someone oh man
I do not know what's going on with the
most basic of technological appliances
um we've got a - easy hello good
afternoon and Joseph Stanley hourly
chest handle is st. Louis Chess Club all
spelled out just like our YouTube
username but no spaces
hello Akshay not aghh
hello you know I'm the worst at
pronouncing names that's fine just yet
let's exercise caution when reading the
handles right make sure that we're not
we're not getting trolled into saying
something that someone might think is
funny
hein Heinrich because we hate humor yes
we just want anti chess yeah oh boy
the challenges are flooding in yep yep
there everyone wants to take old Dennis
down in odd story ins is the story of my
life it's the ultimate privilege they've
been waiting for this greetings from
Germany hello Germany or yes hello
Germany yeah whatever the greeting how
do you say hello all vetoes end I have
no idea cuz I'm good bye let me look
this up translate got a pro researcher
all over this maybe I can learn some
some languages while I'm here
German okay hello ah there's there's
four ways according to google hello
question mark which is hello exclamation
point in English what is happening on
Pato yeah well that makes sense they're
both Germanic languages I can see that
being a thing and then Hollow
exclamation point is also a low
exclamation point this is getting very
confusing can in the Germans and chat
please explain greetings from Algeria
hello star effect yeah hello Algeria I'm
not I
okay there's a countin talk yes yeah
gutentag is the one good day yeah and
then and guten nacht it or night correct
yes and then its service I think that
sounds Latin what did you say see I
can't pronounce words very well so
you're doing good no one is trying to
shame you sure it's except for me Sara
mousse it's not true
yeah I'm not sure that one is beyond me
God after Noah's I might be doing okay
here what do you think it's the Swedish
they took out a bunch of O's from our
good afternoon and it's good Afton or
God Afton Oh today might hello Raymond
and yes five minutes is good is that is
that good with you mr. Dennis yeah
that's fine that's fine I love chess uh
tell me what - I just I'm up to pawn so
I just trade right that sounds right to
everybody involved yes what is it a
little penny - Winnie yep yep no what's
that night doing on b3 who is where
there's no that's all three oh my god
okay new sport yes I can't do math here
amazing I just take any other pin to
make myself feel good what does that
mean rookie one is that what you really
good know that's a big fork come in well
why would you do that - you know I'm
just adjusting random oh we're fine yeah
then you just take on e6 after yeah the
big fork is nothing what are you talking
about
you know you're doing good it's to stick
to translating hello chat room please
tell Lawrence that he's amazing in
whatever language oh boy there's a hello
or Moines in Des Moines yeah that's more
than I can't believe they made this is
used in southern Germany or Austria wow
we are just culturally enriching
ourselves I know this is very
educational
what did I say I was gonna play this
right yeah you could this could even be
a set her baby is anyway can you believe
they named the greeting after a city in
Iowa that's very funny
good game Oh David David he he left very
quickly
haha there's a rumor that there's a
tactical wizard on staff in the club
have you ever heard have you ever met a
wizard of the tactical sort no okay no
must be a hiding
he must be ranked yeah well all I know
is that it yeah well I don't know
anything about anything who thirteen
thirteen Wow Batman Begins you love all
our streams and it's like I know who he
is but I always forget my goodness
Batman Begins fellow is and and we're
drunk lifeguard go it there's no way
it's actually drunk lifeguard is really
Wallace undercover a class saving boy
looking to humiliate I'd see help me out
sir Who am I gonna play let's play
don't get so close because I I'm very
sensitive about my space Bob well
sinister 666 man letter it's just a
username I know the caution cost nothing
yeah PS winners 720 yeah yes there he
has been he's been waiting a good good
deal no no I popular everyone wants to
silence the big mouth you just you get
on the stream you get loud and know like
all we gotta beat that guy you're never
gonna beat me ever mm rated I'm super
confident oh yes branch forced win for
white we already have the psychological
advantage easy easy the exchange and
then they'll resign let's go I'm
flagging you already oh boy or up six
seconds I'm a theoretical encyclopedia
of non chess related theory can you
believe we have five likes already yeah
noticed like I I live my life to be
liked and there was a time that people
used to call me likable Dennis you don't
remember that time and I mean
nothing I didn't know we were telling
fairy tales Oh Lawrence I think there's
some grueling physical labor
what am I supposed to do I'm supposed to
exchange on East Anna is that true I
don't know any of this theory I claimed
to be an encyclopedia of some sort all
right and then I play my bad Bishop for
their good Bishop Mike yeah my bad
because he would have been in the chain
he's bad and now I want y'all my pawns
are on dark squares so my good Bishop is
my light Bishop whoa that's the thing
yeah whoa invisible person I'm talking
to okay and then this is normal
everything is normal all right this
seems like a Sicilian structure please
please leave there's nothing Sicilian
about well all right I'm not talking
haha because I do get this position out
of like when they play the elevator that
or something huh but anyway but there's
a pawn on c5 it has to be there's some
move here that's we just player pawn on
c5 what what pawn on c5 am I supposed to
take it oh no all right huh oh I thought
you're flying in this guy clearly you
are the one I'm flagging I am flying
behind on time oh my goodness oh boy
what am I supposed to do with my life
here as a pawn that is protecting a
knight that is that night oh okay
what this is right yeah is it I don't
know but no yeah you can you can take
you want that you want the b-pawn so bad
take it all right
we're very generous here at the st.
Louis chess club generous reckless
what's the difference is that true oh
I'm not gonna speak for anybody else
oh my god did I just lose something I
did okay what there was no way oh god oh
god oh god oh god I look away for two
seconds in this guy's generous reckless
yeah well that's what I get for talking
and not okay alright that's the one
everyone calm down I said something
about doc give it away a pod then and
then suddenly I look away and a queen is
missing there there may be there may be
someone maybe having a conniption
conniption fit in the production room I
believe I made somebody's eyes bleed
yeah the Queen was hanging all right hey
I'm not a professional okay I don't know
I hardly teach anymore
well I made wishes very close if you're
having an aneurysm and your eyes are
bleeding I can take over the stream all
right you guys need to get checked out
right the yards it's very close yes all
right
seems like our medical emergency sir
everything's fine everybody needs to
calm down Brooke lift yeah big lift just
me just checkmate Lord we just want that
file
what oh no I don't know what you're
talking about all I know is this guy's
getting made it easy no but oh that's a
free pawn I'm delusional I'm just trying
not to let it affect me that I find that
I can't sir I can't tell what there's a
free porn where mmm-hmm what yes I have
no idea what you're telling me there's
it takes that pawn I thought I should do
something about that oh yeah right right
right okay well what'd you do about that
is you defend it with this and then you
give away another fun day pawn is
useless
oh but they have any pawn that is not
useless Oh what do I know
oh yeah I'm nearly a 100 level player
nope Lauren says has actually been
beating me oh did you did you get that
one can you clip that yeah no internet
yeah this guy has beat me in some radio
games I'm not ashamed to yeah yeah he
did it okay we're all proud of him good
for Lawrence oh yeah Lord so just give
me cold storage and cupcakes here Oh
cupcakes here 99 people watching oh my
gosh tell your friends yeah let's get to
a hundred and more yes oh we're at a
hundred gentlemen so if I get louder
does viewership increase yes the more
queens are blunter the better our
ratings
oh we're gonna blunder queens and still
win games you guys just don't know
anything about anything
hmm what's the problem
this guys getting mated you're getting
mated PS winners 720 whatever that means
I'm gonna make you dude it's gonna hurt
you're gonna be sad
it's alright some people are ready to
play three plus two or you be ready for
that kind of responsibility I I am
allergic to responsibility oh I see so I
take care to it on
more pressure more pressure Algeria
how do you say hello and Algerian what
language they speak in Algeria French or
Algeria is Algerian the language I don't
know
alright let's consult that I'm claiming
Google Inc let's see I do not see
Algerian
[Music]
- shuttle danny of i have chances please
help me
Arup is what I would say if I were the
kind of person that looked for handouts
in the world but I'm not I just oh oh
hey you guys eight-six is hanging why
would I take that pawn not a [ __ ]
except I'm a [ __ ] take that's not a
chick
Oh check excuse me check again though
are we going for the draw I'm going for
something um someone tell me what to do
go for the draw okay mines long I I like
a good little practical advice I hang my
queen and I draw games okay that's what
I do
oh I'm glamming it whoa Oh boom yep
what happened hmm I you know five plus a
game good game good game
yes who wants some more undefeated I'm
undefeated I just hang Queens and crush
people with crushing means drawing
alright Danny hasn't lost faith this
guy's full of charisma still we are just
rushing this dream yes crushing it
notice how you did not say that I'm not
losing faith
you always have faith in me alright
that's aren't you don't I just room
fully nice I sometimes I just walked by
and I overhear you saying things like I
believe in Dennis the rule is there's
leadership skills are quite impressive
in an uplifting yeah all right no and
lean closer we're supposed to yeah
because well alright hey a little too
much who's playing who and have you lost
interest so much that you're just yet oh
I'm letting some people know that they
should tune in got it top quality chests
entertainment alright who is this bad
man again person does anybody know oh I
know who he is he is in the chat so
let's few thin man oh well yeah he yeah
he gets so much play from us look at all
you all these games he's played 14 games
that's a lot of games we're gonna crush
it didn't you see my first game I'm
alright
time to summon some people
what are you laughing about sir
all righty okay anyway we're not goofing
around the bishop goes here
Oh who's ahead and development wasn't
this refuted isn't yeah Black's play
refuted by the fact that White has two
more guys out then he looks strong
Center up a bond I don't know yeah no I
recall mr. s women's we should we should
not and people beat let's see what am I
playing alright anyway enough time
controls five oh and under gonna get a
get through
we got challenges you gotta get through
like that's right life waits for no one
what's happening what about before
before going tonight where am I going
yes I'm going to win with two Winterland
for the place where winners go where are
you going where's that night going what
this night yeah wherever he wants to go
man - well let's play a little eith III
action just oh my gosh I refuse to play
on the Queen side dude okay what I want
to do is over here it's not over here
but that nights gonna go over there you
may be right but I am so prideful that
I'm just gonna ignore you in my yes and
being confident with these arrows did
you know you can draw multiple colored
arrows that's really fun you know I'm
gonna play in the center because I'm
just I know everything about everything
well five-oh was included in under 500
for some reason in my head I'm just
talking to the chat don't mind me focus
on your game I don't know how to focus
about on things okay I win
you don't I win here everybody agree
with me please I agree okay
what yes I was yeah
that more like Batman is over why don't
you sack that and then take them well
why don't I do it like this
more forcing right more forcing this way
very least that's a tactical experience
is what you're seeing there yeah Batman
it looks it looks like I just yeah he
just dealt out a complicated line how
did he do that hmm taste oh wow in your
face looks like the Riddler wins again
ìin begins okay okay 246 405 what's
going on here I'm gonna crush you dude
sure you just take that rook didn't take
is what no should I that doesn't that
doesn't sound right to me sir um it just
doesn't oh okay oh my god I'm free oh
good game sir oh my god Batman Begins
yes well good game all right
wow I'm um by your today one draw in two
ins two out of five out of three all
right let's calculate some calculate
some something yep sacrificial master
that sounds scary lightning jelly oh
we've got some guy that's waiting mr.
the hypnotist the hypnotist yes all
right
now I well what's his handle I don't
know it should be the hypnotist he lies
to us Lawrence he lies there's no
hypnotizing us yeah
oh he's gone he's gone all right who
else is in check
Oh Toki sake oh there's a hypnotist okay
all right
Oh 1836 question mark hmm suspicious yes
very okay good luck hypnotist you're on
ah
you're alive he's alive oh no oh my
goodness daddy sub me out this guy's
playing the French what did that even
mean is that uh
oh that's theory or a thing this theory
yeah this is theory dude this is
cutting-edge theory oh yeah right yeah
letting edge oh and I got to get in the
shot get in the shot this moon about to
fall asleep you're gonna fall asleep Oh
what is the structure seems gone without
the bishop
caro-kann without the bishop right yes
well it's the yeah or LightSquared
bishop there's a problem in structures
when you have bones on the line squares
Scandinavian denied all right I'm just
saying that you get the c6 c c6
structure with the open D file okay
every rush in the school but schoolboy
knows okay they just know all right
every every Russian school child knows
okay no need for all right here someone
told me that I was supposed to do
something I wasn't doing but what is
that thing and and does he play 95 and
stuff here what happened okay hmm seems
like the French is a bad no fun line to
find well you know what your your your
values are subjective with social
constructs Lawrence so what is good and
bad
last you go on about uh bar so row says
I've been waiting since the beginning
yeah well we'll get we gave a lot of
people since the beginning of the
universe or the stream yes this guy has
been challenging the very concept of you
since the Big Bang
yeah like several billion years there's
gonna be a human being
this is cosmic level today people it's
just too deep for the average viewer is
too deep for stockfish even that too
before I do anything I'm doing nothing
after who's in chat it's very impressive
which one I don't know all I know is I
don't want to miss a hanging Queen again
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry everybody that
had to see that I'm so sorry
well Scott please forgive me
please please forgive me
let him what's my plan did I have a plan
your plan is to overdraw thank you
he has been waiting since a big being
Wow this guy's been searching for you
searching for
Dennis LaRue yeah releasing December the
holiday season 24 playing guys yeah
we're having a blast playing I don't
know what Jack Jack ready
what uh what a name that just exudes
excitement he's ready I feel like if I
traded off his dark squared Bishop I'd
be okay with okay with life in this
position I don't know has the real chess
player in the room just tuned out he
tuned out after after the crowd wasn't
raking on d4 well I should have brought
a pillow maybe a sleeping mask if I knew
that you were gonna play he six play the
on the on the unbreakable Fort Knox is
that true oh yeah you wanted you want to
try and break into some place where
valuables are kept
don't try Fort Knox buddy but what I
won't try Fort Knox they're gonna get
and smashed or something let's say hello
to some more people hello Marco a low F
life it's like what okay okay yeah yeah
yep he was born ready
Jack Reddy was born right that's very
very nice dr. Reddy that's got a nice
ring to it
yeah and I just want a crush I feel like
I have something crushing here okay
we'll start it with this but what but
what but seems like seems like I'm on
fire but I should stop talking trash
because remarkably good luck
thus far hello supernova oh that guy
yeah so supernova supernova what about
him it's it's the what they call a son
as it's dying right now I'm trying to
piece together this guy bar sorrow is
like waiting for you since the beginning
me the universe then supernova steps in
it's like oh my gosh everything is
coming together and then we have we have
any other cosmic user names in here I
don't know just be careful with those
usernames well we have star effect all
this there's a trifecta please be
careful sir
wow I'm on a veteran I believe you Oh
what happened did I hear something are
you making some threats here I don't
know what I don't know what anything
means why I am where I am in life let's
go yes or essentially don't trade what's
good yeah I almost forgot that there was
there was a guy but then I heard him he
was like it's just like me he's sleeping
yeah he was asleep I'm sorry I'm boring
I know what happened oh oh he woke up
hello Felipe I think I can just trade
here and be ok everybody agree with that
no no he says no there's me shop all
right oh why what yeah I'm making sure
everyone's awake let's just do this
outside in and all that oh close call
ladies and gentlemen was a close call
yeah yeah oh and there there comes my
manic laughter ok let's let's just
ignore the manic laughter I have a
condition you have a condition yeah hey
I
yeah it's called it's called a positive
attitude that's my condition let's see
and please somebody teach me how to play
chess
what is it going on oh yeah we have a
Pippi in human rez because he's gonna
take on that on there dude that's why
and that's stinking it thankful what B 5
play B 5
huh look yeah uh yeah yeah yeah rookie 7
but it looks like rookie 3 causes
problems for this but maybe oh no I'm
crazy I'm crazy ok I don't tend to be a
chess player people all right you got me
absolutely if he takes Kings on age
eight oh yeah yeah but now I play b5 you
can we well now I play this right yeah
oh that's yeah gosh I'm well the thing
is takes rook takes rook takes rook here
yeah I yes I've been doing quite active
you have you have that did I tell how
many times if I told the stream that you
beat me in some reason well I'm not
asking you a minute I'm just I'm just
I'm asking you how many times have I
told them well there's a forecast for a
self-praise showers you know you
surprised me I'm always like yeah that
Lawrence guys whatever and then I mean a
stream work with this guy you know just
like restoring my self-confidence don't
get used to it it's only psyche and so I
can catch you unawares with some nets
like oh my god these things mean things
wouldn't mean bingo Danny I need you to
play for me I don't really know Albert
draw you just play fast he said just
please fast we sack on d4 with the big
old check Oh just slide on over what is
this guy doing went over yeah yeah I
look why would you take it then he takes
the then he takes the rook alright no I
look yeah you messed me up to you mess
yeah yeah yeah it's all messed up life
life is terrible oh now play what it's
all gonna be fine c5 is that true I
don't know yeah never listening to you
again I'm also taking back the nice
things that I was saying oh yeah
rook f7 yeah
[Music]
oops good game if everyone agrees with
me that Lawrence should leave because he
he was the sole cause of my only loss on
the stream I was it like worse listen to
me or is it worse I mean good game I'm
not bitter hypnotist I'm not bitter you
played alright for me to suggest the
moves huh what's worse listening to me
or for me to tell you the deuce things
it's all good it's all good
I'm just a small bitter person so well
this unfortunately this title was not
amateur hour that is not okay good game
good game good game okay I don't want
rematches I'm so sorry
what who were playing who back something
is oh the ones on top so okay shock
mocking oh yeah
or pork tick Bartek has been wanting it
yes all right mister Bartek good luck
let's go get real getting real no more
no more whatever art is doing yeah I'm
on fire and English offer draw just
place c5 and offered wrong nope I'm
flexible I can play whatever I want so
I'll just start with that and go from
there the people get the people get what
the people want this is not boring this
is sharp dynamic some of the world's
most dynamic players play this Lauren or
are you calling yourself one of the most
dynamic players I'm saying some of the
world's most dynamic players I'm not
even a chess player you're only a chess
player if you've done 10,000 puzzles out
of a book okay
book yeah out of a book do you even know
what a book is I've never seen a book
like that some things that you know okay
so a concept of a book to me I looked at
some phone use the hidden antique stores
next to the rotary he finds a bit and
the pagers a written or printed work
consisting of pages glued or soon
together
that still there's a crazy concept
what's a page it's it is where is what
people use for their websites right one
side of a sheet of paper
what's how long the paper is an
abbreviation for pop virus capparis or
cash okay what it right
alright well you got what you wanted
Danny you got some see Zeke's some
position in the Kings endgame
I'm surprised Queen c2 no trade Danny is
engaging in the chest at all yeah he's
also sleep again it's probably bit us
again I hope elliptic what am I supposed
to play somebody tell me all my
principles principles are out here
before you put that night there no you
don't know you know I don't know theory
no asked me what the play and then I say
something I'm playing you're like oh
nope actually there's a v6 looked
correct this is like playing this is
exactly like playing a video game with
your older brother don't do what night
Knight b6 I will not and yeah yeah yeah
my night I knew that what is knowledge
it's like playing with your older
brother in like a video game and then
you're like oh I'm about to beat this
level he said oh no no no no this is the
actual one he takes to control and he
plays all the fun parts and it hands it
to you to like walk all the way to next
city and then you had you had someone to
play video games with as a child
no I'm just visiting that okay yeah the
only child so I really not at all to
what you're talking about you want to
talk about yeah family life get Jonathan
Shantz on this dream you want to talk
about being yelled adjusted oh boy
everyone's teaching us how to you're in
the right place okay what's that
mmm what I'm saying the draughts instead
it seems like a more interesting chess
players play checkers what did you say
to me
mm-hmm don't mind me I don't know what
I'm yeah I'm Way off I've lost them what
I've lost the plot here those French
players moving their bishops backwards
and the rights backwards yeah seems oh
that's a good square for a night yeah
yeah
don't shout the speakers are correct
cranking oh sorry
okay I'm gonna talk real soft now that's
right this is an E is someone real soft
I don't got to turn up your speakers to
hear us and close you didn't like my
bishop being on this square right well
then where is the night going which
night mr. F F FA I don't know put them
back that I'm flagging and I have I've
spent like this whole game just talking
that's right
streaming is more fun when you can talk
in these three oh yeah I'm just not just
not having fun anymore and if they don't
want me to shout then don't want us to
switch they want us to switch well no do
you want to switch oh is that a trap
Queen yeah it's exactly what it is
oh okay yet nope I'm not going oh
there's there's increment here oh we're
fine dude for sure
this is and that's a free truck yeah
that might be a free work Oh God you
know okay Danny's bleeds now
yeah no no you will you know it's bad
when he just God he's just gotten quiet
right no I'm gonna play some atrocious
chest you want to play that's right I'm
gonna play f4 f5 every game five dollars
five dollars all right we're switching
we're switching
got to be nice to chat there's a
lifeblood of art or entertainment
alright now I'm just gonna select the
lowest player lowest rated players you
know attempt to not lose ever again
5o 1400 is there a three-digit rated
player that I could play perhaps just
not
don't shout your speakers are getting
real and then a hole in black I guess I
got to play some terrible terrible chess
are you GM in my GM by who
I don't know if GM stands for good man
than the Pinto if you met grandmasters
and Legos now Danny if you think that
Dennis good game our sorrow
wait till you'll see me what's good boys
you think what's only talking when
you're interesting us you took no dude
what happened here and I told you I
warned you I warned out them playing
this guy big old Michael f5 and I go
back and then I go here or here or here
you know what a free pawn when Nick
risco started playing chess I used to
make fun of him all the time at the desk
because I would walk up and he'd be
doing this like highlighting
highlighting you oh yeah you prepare
look at this look at this very colorful
yes yes is just appealing to your eye
Dennis do you like this oh we've got
four colors that really impress high you
were able to do that yeah yeah I told
you there are multiple colors just worm
you got nothing on this guy hmm
now I calculated all of this by the way
this is all in my head is just floating
you know it's just like yeah
combinations you know did you know your
bishop could move from Bishop on c8 can
move from b8 b6 to ca I did not know
that's a very common theme in this
opening what this is an opening
yes something it's called the russo
gambit are you just making stuff up no
opening series I don't think you want
that oh oh I'm being trolled yeah maybe
or at least yeah so for those of you who
are fans of Nick riscos where's the
thing hmm nothing you look I'm attacking
away your chess over there
is this is this lying is the first step
to failure is the thing that's yes you
should have known Gold quote you could
have also titled the stream wrote to
1600 Road to 16 hi mom mm you're going
on a decline return trip yes
all right so safely yeah 1600 is so yeah
for those of you who are fans of Nick
riscos
chess openings abridged series which is
wait you know what that is I don't
abridged chess openings yeah he
explained like don't worry buddy he's
not no I mean he's not he's not some
crazy Jonathan stronsay class doing you
know go complete Siamese laws in two
hundred parts you know it's
be completely someone says they want to
lose you should accept three oh that's
so we can all be able to play you you
know you're making a moral claim Kevin
MQ alright you're making a moral claim
okay oh boy we should do something okay
it's very deep stuff is it is this also
covered in opening his abridged mmm-hmm
not that I know Oh where's this guy
going he does mean his terms like good
and bad though like oh this is good see
if I have this is good wait it's called
I won Zeus can do I feel this combo is
talking some trash I know
these people are trying to hurt me in
inside but I can only they can only hurt
me over the board
is that true it's deep hmm here here
yeah you're amazing no go forwards and
if he does this I just played this
anyway is that true yeah I see that
reaction now I know not to play it I
would not so you need a GM just sitting
like over there in the camera and then
when I say something he's like then
there Oh what have I done sometimes if
you've ever like I don't know how many
yeah yeah how many times you've played
them but they old like our chest is so
bad that they have to just pretend like
nothing's going on yes they turn off
their brain face to face they've
actually developed the skill for that
hey uniting I know I see that I see that
acting your piece mm-hmm this is
attacked if I take this and then this
happens I just cancel it's not true
wait a minute I drew the arrow the wrong
way it's got nothing on chanson series
yeah yeah we all yes Jonathan Shantz is
a hero to us all right
it's got nothing yeah anyway I was just
setting up for the fact that I'm going
to do my own see which one are you
taking mister huh
ah come on
you're talking to that guy yeah didn't
didn't some famous guy say there's you
can only take one huh yeah you take one
time that's the me called tall thing
about why he plundered
why he sacrificed all this stuff um-hmm
in my talk no I'm only 510 right anyway
enough about you and more about my silly
jokes yeah chess openings identified is
gonna be my new super popular series so
that's what you think okay we're just
gonna hmm
teach you how to identify opening but
how is that useful can you tell the
names of the openings yeah see there's a
demand for this while Oh while playing
oh my goodness well you know what asking
for a lot Terrance can you how did this
can we recipients on YouTube we can't
right Danny
there's no this my charitable are you
feeling question what's the name of this
opening that you're Russo then bit I
want to lose so I play that's actually
in the database I want to lose gambit
I've got the bishop hair undeveloped
just cool it castle this way you know
we're all good here okay we're doing
just fine just like mr. uh mr.
Brightside that's the second time you've
referred to that song yes I don't know
it's just very funny to me Oh boys this
attacked
I have a name for an opening
alright buddies - easy you're you're on
thin ice
there's a Maurice Ashley in the house oh
yeah he's right around the corner he's
screaming at me he's like that's why I
was terrible move now he's good white
has a completely crushing position after
move three I like money I like when he
refers to moves as doozies oh that's a
doozy wait a minute do anything so he
can tell us what does the engine say
about that position um here spoiler the
engines gonna look at any position that
Lauren says and it's gonna say why are
you playing chess lost Allah oh boy long
Singh law good one Kevin good one
mm-hmm I'm hurt I'm hurting that was a
winning combination and I should not be
looking over here yeah your focus is
running down I know and my in my will to
keep playing this game as well are you
already throwing
Oh
what are you doing just take on or just
play don't you just play d2 seems good
you get checked and die lose to the here
can you tell while playing
what else - good one Kevin good one oh
you have know about the barns opening
dentist you know there's me yes I did
know that I did know that I've I have
Google search to myself well this pawn
or this Queen it's hurt now yeah Oh will
he find his way out of yeah five years
ago have you typed in my name you're
you're just gonna get a picture of an
NHL referee now you'll get a picture of
me shoveling coal they did that now look
at that reading a book titled he like he
wants to go here okay what's going on
with you
I mean I I'm yeah you want to play rook
- oh boy II won bro
this was a mistake oh yeah you had to go
there in there oh good game good game
alright who can i play f4 or f5 against
this time
oh why do I always why do we always play
the black pieces no I got I had three
three whites we did yeah if you don't
know how to handle second move then just
get up I just don't know no smells all
this real there might be a real chess
player yes real guy that's I smell some
strength oh boy I lost my first game
very sad 1966 yes the 1960 cool put us
on who's moderating the stream with your
hair uh made him and you got some reason
Leo rode da Vinci says it's got nothing
on Francis series okay worth this game
Nicklaus whatever his name is chess over
tonight what can I fly oh is that a 1300
someone I can actually might win against
black again these people in 60 minutes
so much a video you for you get all the
bishop and how what is this you
sacrifice the exchange on c3 okay that's
already a little too much information
for me
are you watching us so don't have you
been watching and how entertained have
you been by doing it you're not
entertained I'm here to tell you we need
up well why don't you tell you some
stuff why don't you bring a treadmill
here and then my the blood in my body is
gonna start moving well I was being loud
and energetic and they were like being
yelled at I'm being yelled at can i get
hey can you just focus offers table I
can't I can't that is precisely oh no I
can't
hmm I'm looking for I'm looking at you
what's going on how helped me
oh you need help yes you're losing I am
though you want to play something like I
don't know you just want to try and
check me too bro what do you want for me
hold it yeah yeah go to start with that
well I need to get rid of this guy at
least before I play this so you doesn't
go back so I'm just gonna play tonight
here hang stuff Thanks
I want to keep this guy play maybe I
don't know going totally psycho maybe
you want to play e5 and say you're gonna
do something too but I mean you're deep
on is forever weak and you're definitely
gonna die but maybe slow death game
tracker 1996 and also yeah isn't me
except me ghost recon and then also
Kaiba - okay all right
I've been lobbying for assurance to
restart the series for some time now
maybe a placement bullet whatever dude
whatever maybe I can actually play at a
like a 1,900 level in bullet but nothing
else my blitz is just the gray area if
you look at my account okay like what's
going on are you good I'm not have you
thought I'm a recycled at a compensating
that's right some weight yeah you're
compensating for lack of understanding
with your super fast to play I get it
still I hear he's way too much laughter
going on in the control room I am
insecure that it's about me what do you
think it's definitely about you yeah I'm
about to just take this off go over
there laughs and then come back and then
flag alright it's fine I think now it's
gotten too quiet so they're just yeah
they're like mocking that's quietly go
yeah oh yeah feelings too you know we
also have feelings all right okay you
mock me I cry Oh
hmm oh you're you're totally wet what
happened here yeah I'm afraid don't you
uh you're new down material you know you
can get a pawn back and then play oh no
no no no yeah and then play Queen here
and then don't you get one of those two
pieces after I want this though oh I
want this like superficial okay all
right that's an assistant maestro
they're not them I don't know we can I
tell you well he's gonna take it right
so well he's gonna take it takes with a
bishop then I want that so I can go here
is that right okay cause I get five you
do I get five free moves okay that works
because you watch too much chess bras
they are talking to you I've never
watched I the chest bras in my life what
I hate work for them is that can I say
that I don't know but no more escape
thinking it's hard
chest superstar oh you didn't say he
said that he said yeah that's because
you watched too much chest bras bra get
this guy out I expecting this No
Oh shady back backroom deals happening
over there that's right
selling some Magic the Gathering cards
or something here for this small piece
of paper I'll give you a $300 some of
that some of those pieces of paper are
shiny yeah you're good because this is a
good move I think very nice it threatens
meat I don't know why I'm think I'm just
hurting chat on purpose at this point I
get next but you got to play more games
okay you again this is one was just like
having an older brother what I want to
play I'm lengthen the year what's your a
low rating whoo-hoo this guy who he's
not even Lawrence who oh no I trap my
bishop it's not true I am close to my
USCF floor 14 something around there and
Lawrence I don't know you have a
standard rating sir
oh no oh he goes that way do I have a
standard rating 1,200 oh man hey you
hung something I did you have been
hanging stuff all day
young another piece my good bullet ha ha
ha
searching for a way out you know just
crawling Hey
all right we're gonna let Lawrence play
one bullet game and then and then you
guys can play me again hello hello
what's your ego rating yeah I'm like
near my floor and this guy I don't know
if he even has yeah your ceiling your
floors my ceiling please play a game
with me before the game was aborted okay
yeah my wife floor is the ceiling I
don't think I've ever played as badly in
my life that's not true okay whereas was
a fast game very bullet game
let me do some one minute please
oh my seeing something
oh look it's Lawrence who
Oh Oh there's one there's one all right
me when we'll get farmed oh this guy's
strong this guy's strong player weren't
you just saying well how much you admire
Sameach in yes as a they are playing so
1966 okay okay yeah oh they don't know
who that guy was the all the sinkhole of
the game they are playing so bad hey you
know what I was playing great first of
all I lost like one gauge that's were
okay Daniel Denis man whoever you are
okay lost like one game I'm human big
well well what's going on here what's
going on here is we're in we're going to
introduce a very very special guest
someone who whoa I like a lot more than
I like you Lawrence oh yeah yes okay ah
very good Lawrence and I have been
trained and look we're just talking yeah
it's a quote he's going a movie oh boy
oh no oh boy all right here we go I am
about 2000 us yeah it's gonna hide in
the corner Decker want to play a hole we
got a big shot Oh whoo
why do you play so bad Lawrence uh is
that a question
statement I'm about 2000 us
who's that guy who's the Buckeye when he
returned to the seat except only
ghostery corn well I'll pull the I don't
know who that is
Chuck I don't know all right okay the
movie we're talking about is not another
teenage movie no no no this guy just
wants us to play him here was that oh
yeah I was doing great and then I lost a
couple games and I made the mistake of
letting this guy yes
take my J mistake yeah oh it doesn't
want it
yes I just beat you that is me game
checker it's not a movie it's my
username okay it's all been cleared up
the misunderstanding is so many guys you
I don't want to be this guy oh I can
make that excuse as well
kyla too is waiting you were born here
yeah so how does that change anything
about my first language is that true is
that how it is that how the first
language thing is calculated oh boy
too slow all right you're back all right
okay hey Tony trying to play some chess
too slow
you wanna play I know I am hired as a
commentator oh really
Jonathan Jonathan shots you want playing
people oh you are you're Danny all right
I've only set the bar so low thank you
yep yep you you've been relegated to the
peanut gallery yes
never again Oh whoever is whoever was
just playing good job you scared
Lawrence who off I don't want okay we're
gonna play this Kaiba whoever whoever I
don't want to be this guy but Kyle you
know I got you tight but he's where
we're looking for you oh we got it oh my
god everyone calm down all right except
for Tony you you stay pumped Oh who else
wants to play chat us I'll put you on
the list we are since I'm here now we
are playing by bouncer rules which means
you have to be friends with us in order
to play so chat us right status you'll
be on a list also balancer have you ever
been a bouncer have I've ever been about
not at like a club or bar where you
actually need to like push somebody out
of the door but like you know what's
this pretty boy
thank you for talk stop talking good
things about our polos you like this
pretty nice right yeah no hey best
commentator on that's me
thanks man appreciate it nice pose
bad no best commentator somebody just
said out calculated the he I'll
calculate you see all calculated me okay
yeah Lawrence's Amira I just say
inflammatory alright senpai dark senpai
wants to play you're next buddy you're
next why are you laughing me I just
let's be careful with it was some that
ones harmless enough but stay on guards
it on the border well I want to play
calculate is it Nate oh your that's your
name I'll carefully I got you I got you
okay so sorry doctor so we're gonna go
without calculated first and dark sent
by alright cuz you who was I didn't
realize that was his name alright no
well so here's a here's a gentleman
that's asking for to play three minutes
instead of five so we can play as many
games as possible the rule the rule is
five the rule is five that's rule yes it
is I just played like a bunch of random
ones this is why we don't let him play a
lot because he doesn't follow rules so
if you guys like I said last time do you
guys want us to change formats email us
at info as st. Louis Chess Club that'll
work
yeah Danny I need you to put our email
address on there please we need at least
a bullet what was happening info at st.
Louis chest hot war against petition
spam us we don't spam this but tell us
what you know put yeah tell us what you
want putting on a good good word for us
these guys are the best excluding
Lawrence
yeah do we have a manager on duty has
has the man tree actually shown his face
yet on camera you came in yeah you
didn't you this okay berating Lawrence
for losing all our points it was pretty
good me forget good for him good for him
that's lots of points alright here is a
list so far we have number one on deck
out calculated number two dark senpai
number three who is this ghost recon
number four yacht what is that yeah yeah
Toki sake is that okay Toki sake
is that for me anime what's that from
that's uh is that from like fate face
date night is that is that the one I'm
thinking about Oh God
brow face day night you don't like that
nobody's asking me to be here it's not
true that's I did I did actually uh
alright Touche but you know I don't I
don't remember that anymore Lawrence
what are you doing Oh short-term memory
loss so somebody's just saying out
calculated is a pretty cocky name for a
1500 player isn't it hmm
well I mean who is out calculating right
yeah it's true it's all relative
everybody has her everybody has a name
they want to use maybe he's just really
good at math say five minutes fine three
minute results in a more more games play
but in a worse experience playing
screaming for the lucky five minutes no
changing bring that [ __ ] repellent that
was strange unless you get the higher
ups change it for us then you know oh
where is that guy going where's he going
we're Queen g6
dig dig Oh No that's kids it's literally
destroying you're like we're making it
make it fun is out calculated name come
on calm down who is who is what's going
on they're like they they're saying
there was this out carefully this pretty
cocky name and then there was a I
thought he was feeling being all Academy
they weren't talking about you they're
not talking about you guys alright just
a just a refresher just a refresher out
calculator you're on deck next dark
senpai after that I should have taken
what number three it is yeah six was a
dumb move Ghost Recon well you have to
did literally have in insert insert one
one three four write all this down for I
forget about it and anyway oh yeah Tokyo
sake okay grab on you this guy you don't
know chess Lawrence okay you don't know
chess like I know I understand okay okay
I'll calculate his next if you're
playing okay it up you're down on time a
little bit looks like down on time I
might be down material look at that big
railgun that's cool that's cool it
happens it happens
yeah go back what are you saying to me
go back what we're doing here is this
huh what's that remove that what did you
pre move Queen tasted yeah just in case
okay you don't like that you didn't like
that I'm sorry whoa you know I just
noticed it's not Ghost Recon it's
gostrey corn is that the actual I don't
know no it's ghost recon okay no it
definitely has game but like he wrote it
as gostrey corn yeah because he lives in
Iowa he already knows oh really is that
that's pretty badass man why you got it
nobody likes you Oh
dashi Tok Tok yo Socky got it got it
okay good
Daniel Deniz man asks you would you like
to play against me I am weak though I
play chess since July but would be fun
hmm well think about it is that your
user name in light chess as well let me
put you on the list and put him on the
list
you don't listen all right Justin what
problem I wouldn't even know what's
going on anymore I'm assuming this yes
Daniel Dennett I'm assuming that your
username as well as I want to put you on
the list unless you tell me otherwise
hmm okay your pawn take that on c7 I
can't my pawn take the what now the
night are you all ready you're funny you
know teenagers nowadays just uh what are
you gonna is there old what can I say
but already says what hits kids say the
darndest things you know there's TV
shows cook on me back on for that
no one's keeping track because this is
this is a fun stream yeah I mean what I
don't think anybody's keeping track but
all I missed I will keep track from now
on
now that the unicorns in playing the
chair so yeah I'm just good at this game
my user name is Levin toes gone waiting
for you got it you're on the list as
well but there's like five people in
front of you man so I'm out of here
all right dan dan the man you're on the
list as well okay so next is out
calculate it don't don't disappoint our
viewers we have likes left so we're
sorry is that right we have ten minutes
left so we have ten minutes left so
we'll probably get like two maybe two
more games in there so I'll calculate
and darkus M PI you're you're up there
I'll calculate it I'll calculate now
calculated here we go
where are you all calculated I we got it
here we go I'll calculate you're on dark
senpai you're next they're probably just
adjust to do this game
I'm sorry just those two the games left
1507 on Thursday you can play Pepe Kwang
we blame Kings Indian why not what why
not something so just you play yes
so just for six this so just for the
future two Tuesday's like today we
started at 12 Wednesday Thursday Friday
we're starting at 3:00 p.m. for the show
so tomorrow be at 3:00 p.m. we only
stream for an hour
no an hour and a half what that's it
every day yeah you streaming like 12
hours kids say the darndest things right
so we go hey you know what you open at
10:00 which would be streaming till time
does this guy say oh my god what guys
saying oh my god destroyed was a nice
game thank you yeah
thank you sir destroyed according to
chat Ghost Recon you're you're like
fourth on the list so there's only time
for two more games so really asking a
lot though you want to play it record
show weeks and so we need a better this
is my system calm down it's a bad system
the bouncer assists everyone's mad well
you know how they that's just hot c'est
la vie man c'est la vie
you know this gem is asking what your
rating by the way me yes what is my
rating nowadays it is yeah I already
I've said it yeah one near my floor
people in like 14 something us yet or
just say about like 4 or 1450 right in
the middle so this is I guess if you
guys don't know who this is this is
Dennis Larew he is okay he is the
unicorn unicorn up the same with chess
club because I don't yeah but you never
get to see them but then sometimes you
do and it's like whoa still be accurate
does it matter
well it's just there's play the people
now who who like who here thinks I'm
Lawrence raise your hand we actually had
a long discussion about this off-camera
and okay Lawrence and I are you're not
gonna participate in whatever you're
doing
I'm actually asking the viewers raise
your hands I can see I was the second
person after all calculated who is that
what's his name the ghost corn corn let
me look up and I look up it's what
happens after corn
what's happening here my wedding yet
done why am I putting my night there why
not all right
so according to this chat log I'll
calculate it put his name down that's
actually when I sat down so I put his
name not first then it was dark senpai
then we got confused about the name I'll
calculated and then we got Toki sake so
and then ghost recon and then in sir
that's just according to the chat log
all right oh there's a hand race I see
it hey good job good job
you're right yeah all right so after
this we have one more game time for one
more game then it's good it's good it's
dark senpai guys dark central ok we are
here neck tomorrow at 3 p.m. so join us
hey this guy said Lawrence is in the
middle hmm
that was a one out of two guests pretty
good though pretty good
50/50 flip a coin works
come on man get psyched up it's like
that for this game I'm winning on sign
oh yeah was though he's winning on time
I calculated yeah I was talking a lot of
trash all right yeah yeah you're back
all right
Daniel Denis man we'll get to you next
time you come on all right hopefully I'd
be tomorrow 3 p.m.
we'll be here yosef but teehee first
time here welcome probably won't get to
you because we are off of this about 8
minutes or so
come back tomorrow at 3 p.m. we'll be
here yeah bro where's that going
you mean Lawrence Kansas look at that
Lawrence Georgia we didn't know your
geography that's pretty impressive is
that one of the cyclers dvb-t brothers
no I came for Georgia Morgan okay I will
be in school at 3 p.m.
well school will also be here just put
in your headphones you know under the
desk
he's also a student so he can advise you
on some stuff work you know hopefully
you're watching a movie or something
like a documentary or you just couldn't
take a nap or something I hope you're
not in school all week at 3 p.m. because
we'll be here Thursday Friday as well 3
p.m. that's right you got to be
committed so that's you got to be like
mom I'm really I'm really uh I'm feeling
really sick I need to come home you know
at 2 p.m. yet I like set this up
strategically you got to be like oh my
head hurts and mom picks you up at 2:30
you're home by 3:00 you can play us easy
easy win that's tactics for you that's
real life tactics I don't know what to
say about that I mean I don't know I'm
assuming you're not in the type of like
in high school where you need your
parents to pick you up oh you know he's
pretty young it's like he might be in
that situation well like if you're in
college you just
get ya for the record we do not condone
skipping school
we're just saying you need to if you
want to play chess you might have to
that's right I mean if you prioritize
playing us over you know school well I'm
just merely suggesting a way that you
can make that happen but I think that
it's a good idea right you just third
facts do you need some music to pump you
up Lawrence I just need to learn how to
play chess
yeah what's this bad boys bad boys what
you going into you're winning on time
Renan and position what's boom out
calculated your chest students out there
yeah boom witness a kobe instrument so a
Kobe in will be our Grandmaster in a
residence starting I want to say what is
it I know it November 20th maybe what
happened I think bar yeah I think I'll
coping is next Jamie residence like end
of October
so he'll be streaming again Bob that's
the Hawaii 500 us a soundtrack
we got a for you what what's your song
what's your song here my song yeah what
do you want to listen to Wow
Bishop hey one activated my song is I'm
gonna crush people that's my song I've
never heard that it's a great song and
also I just got for it hey look he says
I am in high school and they are taking
our phones when well it finishes I am in
Turkey and it's 9 p.m. now oh that make
that's putting a lot of things in
context thank you well you're gonna want
to go out and buy a second phone so you
can hand it in and they'll think okay
this kid only has one phone but in
reality you've got to so he he grew up
pretty privileged so he has multi has
multiple phones for those of you making
for those of you who cannot do I need to
go hello
good game I'll calculate it tweet we
have time for another game darks empires
next dark Sun senpai you repeated a lot
last one dark Sun guys go make a count
make it count go give me a challenge I'm
too strong for you guys strong he says
thank you for the game sir
I mean good game thank you thank you he
says I certainly got out all calculated
they're good good you know way to be a
good good sport way to be a good sport
all right now d3 BAM
v3 Danish yeah English well no no the do
you guys are Wow now I yeah yeah
I make Danny hurt when I talk about
chess this is a semi slow ok ok ok
you gotta go so this guy's saying to our
taunts for I'll calculate it yeah join
us in taunting yeah yeah yeah it's all
it's all in good fun
all right no if you can't get another
phone that's what I say when so we have
a couple of people here from Turkey
playing with us Wow Wow yeah I'm very
impressed that's awesome that's Austin
bull there's a historic and amazing city
have you ever been who's been to
Istanbul I'm not I would like to though
I'd like to you can't afford to phones
all the plane ticket in a visa all right
that's a support group so if you're
asking what Dennis the unicorns reg
rating is is about 1400 or in the word
like you know in the spirit of Nick
risco I'm currently 1415 USEF but I'm at
least like this congressional masters
train don't you two ever talk over my
jokes again Lawrence if you do that oh
my goodness
oh man you have you guys has anybody if
anybody watch the show legends of
tomorrow where those like a unicorn and
then he attacks people that's what's
going on me if you can't call me a
unicorn I stand up I'm standing up for
my right yeah hey on my worst day on 14
huh
doesn't that mean your arena feed a
master eye is that what that's what make
Chris go says right yeah yeah he's an
arena I I just can't talk anymore he's a
theoretical 1,400 you guys better used
her titles when you're referring to mr.
Arena defeated master Dennis LaRue yeah
yeah make some big bucks so what do you
know about before yeah this guy says if
you play me now you can stay in my house
for free while you are in my Yuri is
them alright would you like to uh
unfortunately we are literally out of
time after this game we would actually
love to next time for sure next time
great offers yeah that's a terrific
offer and then two pieces for the for
the Queen you're smart
oh but don't sack these two pieces for
the night takes you are ridiculous
Lawrence don't ever suggest moves to me
ever again please
so you're being attacked huh or so
you're being attacked so you just give
stuff away mm-hmm is that is that what
they're teaching you is that place what
do you think Dennis should do here guys
any any suggestions open suggestions
before getting forked is not dark senpai
what's your rating I forgot him from
theater day are you like uh everything's
fine here I mean on here you're sixteen
thirty viable Witcher is that accurate
are we looking like eighteen hundred
I remember saying something about that
this guy he is up a whole piece so I
can't talk a whole lot of trash right
now better dang well he you're up at
peace dark sent by this is like the
other day were you just like stomping on
people's throats and I'm like just who
is stomping on who's there also don't my
play parried the other day and it was
basically like he had his like foot on
stone just like pushing down slowly
that's how I felt the other day it's
looking like the same thing so good job
I am I am I feel threatened and insecure
by the volume and amount of laughter
coming from the control room Tony yeah
are they talking about sure they're
laughing about it could be me why would
someone left so are we the strongest
players the world has ever seen because
yeah it's yes so viewers those who do
not remember Danny Machuca is in the
back room making sure everything goes
according to plan on the show can we
Danny can we put a mic on you so you can
talk join the conversation is that a
possibility he's like The Voice if we
did put a mic on Danny the sound he
would hear the most is gentle weeping
yeah so unfortunately he said no maybe
one of these days we'll do like a joke
thing and just put a camera like a put a
camera and microphone by him so he
doesn't know it it should be like a face
cam right like he's wearing a GoPro on
his head that's not a bad idea I like
that I like that mean GoPro first-person
chess stream to be funny Danny the
crusher Machuca join us I play this mind
because of the faith the famous Danny
Machuca Machuca massacre in Pasadena
2000 something so my choucas nicknamed
it the Chess Club is the crusher wait
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa yeah how does
he become the crusher and I'm the
Unicorn so the the reason behind this is
because his last name Machuca is a
derivative of mature car which means to
crush that's what he explains he could
be lying to me I don't know that's why
I'm sure that's true yeah sure I don't
know actually he's wrong actually must
be got is to chew he's buying tea but
you trying to hurt me first
oh he said murder Danny's hurt he's hurt
okay I don't you know oh and you know
what Tony you just reminded me that
Danny Machuca he's a nice guy
oh he's a nice guy but you know I think
he's gonna sabotage my mic
and or oh that's not true oh is it in
there again okay so wait here I got you
I got you cuz I see it over there we're
gonna that's the 30-second delay
anything do that are we good
I probably kicked it out yeah we have
some oh you see that thing at some point
yeah I got it I'm all over no barrel
plug this one yes quick turn the camera
so you can see Danny he just ran away
dang it okay yeah I I call you eunuch or
not because that's it like make fun of
you that's a legitimate how do you not
want to be the unicorn like the one that
you everybody yeah little cuz little
girls have like posters of unicorns I
don't want to be like the thing in
Orlando Bloom what do you what do you
want wanna be what do you want to be
think about this think about well
there's already loser the road the road
tactical do you mind one word one word
you want to be you can be called good
you can be called the no no the demon
won't do that alright it has me okay
with being called it has now been
officially changed it is Dennis the
demon LaRue yeah really no well LaRue is
also French for a road so it's called
demon road now demon road okay Wow
we're just kidding I said by your you're
beating him violate yours - good job man
good job yeah this guy is hurting me
it always very drops every time I see
you play against Perry against this guy
you're just you're just dominating
everyone hurts me stopping me road take
me home we don't we don't do that here
that was quite offensive yes it was it
was very offensive to my ear that you
kidding me hahaha oh my god this guy
this guy's saying demon is good and also
El Diablo he's gonna be yeah yeah yeah
we'll take that into advisement yeah
okay yeah yeah lean closer and watch me
lose oh hey Tony dark side fine I'll pay
you ten bucks to quit right now
don't say that
hey and white oh oh my god I do not know
how to use this man okay did you tell me
to grow up
[Laughter]
all right good job yeah yeah okay all
right tomorrow we will be on a 3:00 p.m.
please join us then he's gonna be on you
and me again I'll be on the who else is
gonna be playing I'm the colorful
commentator Agron my stroke okay big
wanker we're gonna be talked about
various things if you want anything you
special you want to talk to this ball
please chat us otherwise info as same
let's check out that ward thank you very
much for joining us thank you I have a
wonderful day